hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry
and I'm Murray and we're gonna watch a
special video today called a hundred
ways to attack the groin
oh this is a highly recommended video I
could use this information a lot of
women come after me and sometimes you
gotta get them away from you so you got
a punch them in the groin vagina punch
the agile move imagine any kind of
growing punch Birds yeah any copy very
much hurt it hurt yeah bigger sank girls
can handle it way more
I don't know step pressure they used to
wait on their vagina in their vagina so
vagina punches on balls is a state of
being girls like to have a full punch
inside of their vagina
they call it misty that's not a punch
though that's like it that's like a
gradual thing yeah but you know some
girls you know it causes a shine it
extend yeah but you don't
I imagine why wouldn't I just oh it
looks like the t1000 to ease into that
know it you punch it and then your arm
gets sucked in it's a horrifying
nightmare I don't think that's how it
goes that's how it goes Murray back me
up here you're a woman um I have never
been punched on me in tried of manager
well it's about time I learned how to do
that this video got off to a very
interesting story and when we did
Taekwondo we eat we [ __ ] head Bob
there's another Bob they look like Ken
and Ryu
yeah or SAR versions of Kevin Orie or
Tom Lennon and a guy I used to work with
here we go master Kennedy here to
announce that Tiger Tuesdays are back in
action and in order to celebrate our
100th video upload to our YouTube
channel today we will be showing you 100
different ways to attack the groin we're
gonna do that now yeah I didn't bring my
cup that's why
actually what I like to call blunt-force
comedy just keep pounding that one joke
until you warn everybody down enough
that they'd start with well they sense
of rising you at times too well yeah
it's like you think everything creative
for some creative nut punch I know all
the ones that were like made no sense to
attacks without obvious one that's half
the fun because there are only so many
ways that you can attack somebody's
growing so they gotta throw it some
creative ones it was a good time
that's funny the ones that are getting
ready show that to people but recommend
this to my friends and family
let me see if I can arrange of screening
someone well dudes so many of you guys
told me to watch this video thank you
that's a great [ __ ] job I loved it is
a minute of enjoyability if you're new
to this chanel you can subscribe here
and um and I'm Dan Cyrus you're the new
Sally Oh what but but she's always been
marine but I'm nothing like Sally yeah
it's true you're just you okay Fisher
more like Sally my groin it was taken
where's the guy there's just a whole it
we got shoutouts to do Alejandro Baker
Mason Alejandro Baker Mason said Ryan
you guys are amazing
and you're funny as hell bro you've got
to be one of the realest people on
YouTube and I'm mad respect for you bro
can I please get a shout-out I
understand here you get a lot of
requests so I understand if it takes a
while by the way all the women on your
channel are beyond beautiful
sincerely Alejandro Baker Arlen Madsen I
like that you read that like Barack
Obama yeah no is it by Barack Obama
rhythm run you guys are amazing and
funny as help yeah Ryan I mean that's me
actually
Alejandro bro you've got to be one of
the realest people on YouTube and the
United States of America I really I
really think it's I really appreciate
the message I think it's really sweet I
feel like if you really care
and you could have written realist with
two E's and I'm real oh yeah every time
you say real yeah wait what why why do
you help realist cuz he's cuz you're
like the real is how he should have said
re yeah yeah so that's what you're hung
up on on this one well I just think that
if they really cared about like the
channel like cherry on top of his
comments but look what is this image
you're trying to create marine I've
worked hard to build an image of a good
caring gentleman on this channel and you
are tainting my image but I thought it
was clear that every time I came on here
man did shout out that I was gonna
insult the subscribers no okay
I guess that's your thing was just
joking am I am I being too hardens no
mister everybody is following hippy nah
dude
Alejandro Baker Mason you say the girls
here beyond beautiful you're beyond
beautiful you're batman beyond beautiful
man yeah good show Terry Terry that was
Mary
Oh Terry the one who looked like a woman
in the Batman suit very very honest I
think so far he's Irish oh why is that
chick with flat tits running into
Batman's chicken Terry was pretty hot
like if he was a guy in real life and he
looked like that I would be like yeah
and let him suck my dick but let him son
might exist given that that would
certainly be a choice since he's yeah
Batman Jaden McBride I got a shout-out
good for you Omar marques dear your show
is great to watch while I'm smoking some
weed [ __ ] hilarious
can I get a shout-out please that's
actually kind of Awesome
that is awesome just to know that for
sure a lot of this channel you know one
of the key secret ingredients is
marijuana for everyone everyone is high
all the time on the channel yeah all you
guys are stuff you guys are all stoned
right now Terry actually we get Mariko
Kansas should wake up a little bit yeah
so doesn't do much because we balance it
out with some this is a lot
yeah a presence is what we get SSO you
guys want some antidepressant yeah
you'll be feeling marginally more normal
again in no time
it's gonna be awesome dude you should uh
um wanna party with your antidepressants
actually sounds like a recipe for like a
pretty good couple months no cocaine an
adderall it would make for some
interesting dream well I don't think you
would need I don't think you need
cocaine and adderall you really only
need one of the other well cuz
adderall's like speeds I mean I'm
talking cuz in Scenario I'm gonna be
crushing matter all morning and I'm just
gonna be like taking it but the
recommended I don't know DiCaprio and
the wolf of Wall Street he would do coke
in the morning and then he would say to
adderall's
so I think uh I mean if you you know
wanna make what they make do what they
do that's what I say hey I like to smoke
weed and chill out watching your show
that's like I just need to be that for
somebody because I imagine I know Omar's
gotta be lightened up a joint when he
wants to relax you know chill out yeah
you know after a long day so that's kind
of cool the target demographic is mainly
stoners actually really oh that is the
target demographic me more polish yeah
we were trying to inclusion upon just
like just nail a nug to the wall so it's
always thick I mean if we could get pot
heads dude imagine if we started selling
food on this channel
where are we shouting more but we will
send you cookies yes we will send you
bags of Funyuns Oh graham crackers
chocolate and chocolate Godiva chocolate
that's the best when you're high that if
how would I know that have totally been
out before I don't know what I'm doing
thanks Omar yeah marques do you told you
Latino market that's what we're really
at right now we're really targeting
Mexico um I don't think that most of
these years are in Mexican I think 95%
of them are Mexico or Indonesian
probably probably Latinos living in
Indonesia that makes more sense that
makes more sense very rapidly changing
demographically that's true people have
really evolved it's kind of like the
u.s. you know like it was primarily
Irish and people British now it's
primarily African Americans the whole
country is primarily African Americans
that and el Salvadorians where are you
getting your statistics life really
based off you know I just walked out
three how many people I see if I see
eight black people one white guy and
somebody who looks vaguely Hispanic then
I can assume that eighty percent of the
population I say so many things like
that like as if I'm being serious and
people actually question me that was
especially nonsense well yeah we do walk
the dangerous line between do they
really think that's true are they
selling absurdity with a straight face
dill pecks gaming can i have a shout out
Ryan been a fan for a long time how long
are we talking here though man
have you hasn't really been a long time
with them a long time do you like two
months or a year what do what is it what
is it be more specific
yeah cuz I mean a long time is a very
relative idea yeah absolutely like if
it's a long time since you meet and it
could have only been ten hours but
exactly
eggs-actly right insulting but do you
know you piece of [ __ ]
yeah Oh [ __ ] dear I think that's had
it covered
oh no no no more the nice one I don't
want it why no but you were like what
like how long
long time me old man here's the dynamic
of how shadows work Ryan's the really
enthusiastic one who do you know like
charts them all I'm the guy who usually
has some kind of weird comment on the
process of people making really harsh
demands in return for shoutouts and then
you're the one who talks shut up people
uh will do pecks gaming um I find the
the first part of your username to be
strange I don't understand the spelling
or one of his I don't know if that's
like your last name but I hate it and I
hate you no that's too much I don't know
if that's too much you really want to
before is my problem is we've made you
like you've now self-aware of your roles
and now you're trying yeah yeah like
instead of just letting the vitriol flow
like you have Johnny Depp in the Pirates
of the Caribbean movies like now I gotta
try to be with it when I feel like I
need to be meaner like I need to be like
I wanna be as you mean is I need a goal
it's a hurtful I know I need to attack
their personal life mcdhh I need
everything to cyberbully to look except
I don't come at all so far I don't want
to hurt you go pecs can't quit you
Dilbeck anyway dill pecs thank you for
being a bad thank you hopefully you
enjoyed your absurd shout out this is a
little long shout out so if it really
has been that long at least it just no
it all over centers around you really
and started with you and then this was
the you know act to and then now we
brought it back to the finale here
I feel like instead of shouting out
people's names people should give us a
word or phrase they want us to say yes
that would be fun yeah like honest
trailers yeah oh yeah I do okay never
mind
Oh steal that I think we're done with
the beat I think we are